So here's some examples of models and
these are the same transformations that
we talked about earlier when we're
talking about doing mappings for
homographies and panoramas,
and things like that.
So we have very simply so we basically
go from the red to the, the green.
So if we have a translation, right,
so this thing just move that way.
And in translation,
how many unknowns are there?
>> Two.
>> Two, right.
So since we get two equations for
each point,
we just need to track one point here,
one point there.
If I know that between them, I know
how x changed, I know how y changed.
Two equations, two unknowns.
Great, everything is good.
We have what's called a similarity.
A transform similarity is where things
can translate rotate and scale.
All right, and
that's four unknowns, two points.
Which if they, think about it.
If I take a stick here, I can translate
it, rotate it and stretch it.
I only need two points to know
the translation rotation stretch.
Much more interesting is
what's referred to as affine.
I have this rectangle and
when I move it,
I can translate, rotate,
skew, all right?
And so, parallel lines remain parallel.
And I have six unknowns.
And, and there's, we,
we actually looked at the math before.
One way to think about it is,
I take one triangle, and
I map it to its corresponding triangle.
And that's an affine transform.
So the six unknowns, and
I can solve it with three points.
And then finally, I know you're
all waiting for this, right?
Here it's written as perspective,
we can also write this as homography.
Now you're seeing why we don't
have me writing anything.
We did this before right?
We said if we have perspective
projection of a plane
to another plane that,
that transformation is a four-point
transformation, eight unknowns and
that's because it takes four and four
points therefore to recover homography.
So each of these can be thought
of as transformations or
as motions within a region.